i had one of my greatest fights on
canada really wow yeah i got detectives
really yeah amazing
what was the experience what was what
was that you remember
[Music]
welcome everybody to another episode of
hot boxing
hot boxing with my man mike tyson i'm
evan britton
mike how are you man i'm doing pretty
good this is pretty interesting
yeah we're all smoking here yeah now
we're actually hot boxing this thing
um happy thanksgiving to you guys happy
holidays
thank you uh thank you very much yeah
man we've got a great guest in
in the house tonight at the ranch
tonight today
kyle turley former all pro offensive
lineman one of my
childhood heroes mike
i mean seriously kyle kyle brought me
into
the cannabis game really he invited me
to
speak at my first cannabis conference on
the first panel
and really got me into this world um
that that i've you know obviously it's
become my life at this point my passion
um kyle welcome thank you yeah it's good
to be here
[ __ ] um i'm listening all this stuff i'm
sitting next to [ __ ] mike tyson
right [ __ ] man he's talking about me
you can come closer thank you thank you
for having us here
appreciate that my pleasure thank you
thank you yeah man
well kyle i mean we
we come from you know the same same
background offensive line
um played in the nfl and and that's
really what's brought us both to
cannabis
and talk a little bit about you know
what you're doing here i remember even
still playing football
seeing you on tv giant beard long hair
talking to bob lee
on outside the lines about why the nfl
and why football needs to embrace the
cannabis plant
talk a little bit about that man man
that was like
uh 10 years ago yeah almost
10 years ago i think that was 10 years
ago
on outside the lines you know i was
touring with my band
i was playing music at the time and uh
something was happening and they you
know wanted to talk about
uh you know something in football i
can't remember exactly what it was
opiates you know and
we keep we keep having this conversation
you know about opiates constantly
and and we know as cannabis users
there's an
alternative you know to opiates we don't
have to be on all these pills
and i unfortunately at the time i was
still
on a lot of pills um i didn't think so
though because of how many pills we were
on
yeah we were on so many that like having
five a day was like you know i was on a
couple you know but it's like [ __ ]
like laura tabs and
you know he's uh he
super high po potency opiates you know
that unbelievably damaging and gets you
high as [ __ ] they feel good though
they do right they do uh unfortunately
those things make you feel real good but
um you know what what my experience was
in dealing with post uh contact sport
life
uh was that the cognitive uh
effect that those sports had was was
something that those medicines and how
good they made you feel
just never resolved more than cannabis
did cannabis was always that one thing
and so with bob lee there you know
saying that i you know i think that
there should be more you know discussion
about this
plant that grows from the ground that
has this opportunity
uh to be a tremendous medicine for us
uh you know i i'd only touch the surface
of what
that conversation is now yeah at that
time yeah what kind of response did you
get from that
uh but i uh i i thank you and saying
bob lee said i i i i'm assuming you're
talking about
uh uh cannabis
i said yes bob that's the one and you
know after that then we've had all this
other stuff
since then we've had all this other
stuff we've been in the super bowls
we you know we've been to houston we've
been all these places
and you know what's happened since then
is they just keep talking and we just
keep doing
and unfortunately they don't seem to
want to help they don't really want to
help this movement
you mean you mean the big big
big media the espn the league
yeah everyone everyone every big media
does not want to help
cannabis right they've they've kept uh
this conversation in the dark uh
for so long i mean mark stepdowsky
before you know
as a football player i guess i'd become
the football guy but but mark stepnowski
was a guy who played for the cowboys for
15 years you know he was a a center at
amazing 250 pounds or 260 like and a
small you know just undersized guy and
uh was all pro you know helped help the
cowboys to super bowls
and uh this guy retired from the nfl
after a 15-16 year career and moved to
canada
for marijuana and was actively talking
about this
back then like we are that's amazing
yeah
so the response i mean it's just lip
service
unfortunately you know they don't want
to listen to us and then when they see
this and you know they'll see the
smoking thing you know
and uh you know big tobacco's done a
great job of making everybody believe
that smoking's bad and
you know when they were telling
everybody that was good and they had
cigarettes in the operating room and
yeah uh
ashtrays right next to here while a
woman's having a child
you know yeah no [ __ ]
but now it's really bad you know has it
ever
you all the speaking and all the
advocacy you've done
have you ever gotten a negative response
from the people that matter
you know like have you ever because
you're you're in there man you're
talking to the league you're
you're not you know at all
um you know hesitant on any level to get
this message out there
and what is the response from the the
higher ups the lip service i mean
you know the nfl's been talking about
this for a while now and it seems like
it's more and more
yeah uh you know i've gotten some
headway you know
i've been able to move the needle a bit
um with them
um you know i've just stayed i guess on
the path of
of proving this you know as we were
talking earlier today he was like man
you keep looking better
yeah my little brother was the other day
talking to me about uh
uh you know talking to me about man i
got more gray hair than you
and you know and i'm just like well i
everybody keeps saying i'm looking
better i don't feel better as i said
physically
my body feels like [ __ ] you know that
that's the game and what it does in
these sports and things we do
um but as far as the body is concerned
appearance and everything else i i've
gained some youth you know i've turned
back the clock in
a lot of ways to where i was headed yeah
um and so that perseverance of
constantly
showing up to super bowls constantly
being on the radio
of you know progressing this of of
standing here with and sitting here with
uh
a joint in my hand and
you know talking about doing something
that i
was adamantly against growing up you
know i mean i grew up
mormon uh i then played football you
know the
the the i saw guys get lose scholarships
over weed
uh you know i thought you know [ __ ] damn
those guys you know they [ __ ] ruined
our season you know
but now it's the you know i understand
it wasn't them it's the
ncaa we should have been using this then
right you know
um and and uh so that's why i do this
now that's why i
continue to you know just push the
button
and hopefully they answer the door
nobody wants to sit in their house
there's somebody standing outside the
door
pushing the button the ringer
or knocking on the door you know i'm not
going anywhere
your guard dogs have already walked past
them they know i'm the alpha
i'm gonna stand here you know until you
[ __ ] listen
right because this is real and along
that route now i've gained a lot of
you know knowledge about this plant and
tracking down all the
people that uh are knowledgeable about
this that i can gain that knowledge from
yeah like rafael mashulem and all these
people and
uh from from her to uh
dr benedo malu who i had a conversation
with about this you know
he was one of the the guy they made the
concussion movie from yeah that will
smith played
and he told me he said kyle i see it
then you keep smoking it
i love that that's what that's what i'm
talking about dude
yeah that's [ __ ] great man i mean the
the headway you're you've just been such
an inspiration to me man
on this whole thing i remember that
first panel i did
we did together and
i'm sitting there and i'm not exactly
sure
if what i'm saying matters at all you
know talking about my experience using
cannabis how it was just
much preferred to me than the pills in
my football career
and i hear you make this statement for
the first time i'd
i'd never heard this before and you read
off the federal government has this
patent
on cannabinoids as a neuroprotectant an
antioxidant and i was like
holy [ __ ] dude and that was in like the
70s or something like that
it did that a long time ago right yeah
when did the the pattern get like in the
60s no no no the patent didn't come till
the 2000s i think
okay they knew about it you know yeah
that's when in 1970
1974 that's the date to google search
that's the birth of big pharma and uh
the
uh when marijuana became the war was the
war
the real war on marijuana began and
but then in 2000 that's when 2003 i
think the patent lists
yeah i think it's 2003 or 2006 even i
don't know something like that
yeah is when the united states
government filed a patent for
cannabinoids cannabis as a
neuroprotectant an antioxidant
so which means it protects the brain
from damage
and it helps the brain brain heal
following damage
and i was like man my whole football
career
makes sense you know why
you know anybody you can feel the
effects you know i was
very much like you very straight laced
growing up
you know weed was something that i was
horrified
if somebody found out i ever smoked weed
you know being a leader and captain of
my football teams
um you know and so to
find out that yeah man that feeling i
had when i would
me and the o line we'd you know smoke a
joint and then the next day
i'd get the best sleep of the year you
know that night and wake up feeling
refreshed like i could go hit a practice
i could go play in another game i was
like man why is it doing that to me
you know i'm i thought this was this
this party drug that you know
no athlete should ever touch you know
whereas if i drank
had you know one too many beers one
night you wake up the next day feeling
like [ __ ]
yeah i didn't understand that you know
the whole time i was in college
again i grew up mormon i didn't drink i
didn't smoke i
i committed to the dream that was what
it was yeah i was getting out of moreno
valley california
you know i didn't grow up in the coast i
didn't grow up rich
i was the son of a truck driver five
kids uh
you know he was a failed farmer we
farmed for uh until i was ten
i could drive a combine a hay baler
you know do all these things my dad
would throw me the keys when i was eight
years old and tell me go change the
water on the back property
uh growing up you know and and then i
moved to southern california and then my
dad just went trucking full-time and
then ran out and we had divorce and all
this i was on my own
and i was like i got to get out of
mourinho valley california
i cannot stay here i need to surf so
because that's what i grew up doing
and uh you know it was a commitment to
the dream
so i didn't do any of this stuff i
stayed away from all of it man and i had
the same experience
you know when it was introduced to me
for the first time uh
from a hall of fame player uh he said kt
you you need to you need to smoke this
man he said
i mean at the time i was probably you
know i'm writing all
i mean it was in a very uh it was just
this this time of my life
what did he see and you just said you
need to smoke this yeah
for sure man what did you look like i
had well i was
i was fading i had a lot of stuff you
know you you you make it big
like i got drafted in the first round
you know that's like being a
the heavyweight champ of the world you
know for sure i mean it was
insane and uh uh millions of dollars all
of a sudden right out i was making 720
a month on the scholarship check yeah so
then i got you know married real quick
you know had the first marriage uh
gold digger the whole deal you know
right so i had that situation and i was
going through this divorce
we had just had a baby so you know we go
in and out of courts all the time like
dealing with all this stuff
you know real world [ __ ] that everybody
deals with
um but it was affecting me on a whole
nother level you know i
i had this whole you know idea of what
that was supposed to be and it got
yanked you know it was like damn i got
it i got took
you know um and and and so that and then
the whole kid thing so there was a lot
of
you know and then the courts and then so
no sleep you're dealing with lawyers all
the time
yeah you know when you're trying to be
an athlete you have to be on call at the
time because they might come and arrest
you because your old lady
said uh you know she filed a restraining
order against you or some stuff you know
and
in you know making up all these things
about you because she wants the kid and
she wants the money
and you're just in this you know
hopeless a helpless situation
you know i was in that like my third
third year of the league
and you're like 20 22 years old you know
i'm just like
i mean anyway so all this off-field
stuff you know that everybody else deals
with in the real world right boohoo [ __ ]
it whatever so
but i have to go perform at this job
that that requires me
to uh fight every day you know
uh as an offensive lineman in the era
that i played
in the national football league it was a
fight every day we literally went to
practice
uh we watched you so we could learn
moves because we were we were fighting
that day in practice that's what happens
between the offensive line and defensive
line yeah it is uh
a war a war the whole practice every
even your own teammates every day
um you know pads or notepads uh just
a war and then the game and everything
like that
um and i was fading because i wasn't
sleeping i wasn't eating right you know
everything was failing me um i didn't do
drugs i didn't drink
you know so everybody knew like what was
happening
you know kyle uh you know he was going
through this time
and uh you know a lot of people were
surrounding themselves around me
and you know this one player said kyle
you need to you know use this
he's like he stopped peer pressure yeah
you know peer pressure but he saw me
getting all these prescriptions from
these doctors you know they're giving me
i was then introduced to uh sleep aids
and muscle relaxers to help me sleep and
all this because i told the doctors i
can't sleep you know i'm sorry i'm
dealing with all this
i'm getting surf papers at the saints
facility you know
down louisiana you know [ __ ] i'm just
like ah
[ __ ] so much stress yeah and um
you know so this situation just created
this thing where i was
just fading fading fading introduce the
cannabis long story short
uh i said no way i can't risk my you
know career i can't jeopardize this
right now
he said kt you've already taken the test
i said what because college is
random right and they're still randomly
testing collegiate athletes which is
[ __ ]
yeah they shouldn't test it yeah they
shouldn't test at all they should not
test for cannabis so they don't test in
high school so why are you testing in
college what are you testing it for
right and now we understand there's a
cannabinoid system you should be
researching this not testing for it yeah
you know so
anyways i didn't understand the nfl's
policy of
uh you you only take one test for street
drugs a year
so i don't know how boxing was but in
the nfl if you pass that one test
it was on you could do cocaine you could
do anything
but as soon as i took cannabis man uh
that was it
i knew right then and i went on to have
all pro season the rest of the year
because he he approached me right at the
beginning of the season
i i got served papers in training camp
and then
uh that's that was it i and crazy i
could sleep i could
eat i i was back i had this vitality you
talk about
back you know my mind i wasn't stressed
you could call it what you want
detaching yourself away from your
problems
i don't care okay sometimes you need to
detach yourself away from
the greatest fights on cannabis wow yeah
i got detected and i had to pay a big
fine
really yeah it was a great fight amazing
mike
what was the experience what was what
was that you remember
relaxation
i felt that too but i was playing call
of duty so it was a little bit different
could you did everything just slow down
and you could see things becoming better
your
your your your vision yeah i was kind of
like an animal too but
yeah i stopped them in the second round
but i caught when they had to
take my urine testing they felt the
marijuana and they called it a
disqualification ah damn really when was
this
um andrew collada for andrew
collaboration andrew gulotta yeah
probably 2000. huh wow man that's some
cannabis history there
yeah hell yeah right there man that's
pretty amazing
that's all the athletes that i've talked
to since you know yeah that's the
experience
just across the board yeah it's just
it's better for sports uh
in my experience it helped me i didn't
and now knowing strains and all these
other things
of your experience and you know with
certain strains that has really
developed your opinion now on cannabis
uh
my my experience has been just these
strains that are available
you know that are now that we know so
much more in cbd
yeah you know cbd is amazing you know
it was interesting what you were saying
earlier about sativas being better pain
relieving
mike likes sativas yes i have always
liked sativa yep yeah
very cerebral there it give you clarity
uh i i read an article today too about
um there's actually benefits to eating
raw cannabis that they found now because
the thc
acid uh before you there's a lot of
health benefits
super we've seen a lot of weird salads
now oh yeah excellent
salad you know it's a super food it's a
super fuel
it's kyle juice is it yeah right yep
every
all the all the plants that i harvest at
the end of it i
take all the stocks everything and put
them in the pot and boil that up
get everything out of that and then make
your intent and then make sure that make
a tea out of it yeah
you know who knows i just know for the
last four and a half years now almost
five
i have not touched one opiate not one
painkiller not one muscle relaxer not
one sleep aid not an aspirin not a leave
not
anything i had bottles and bottles and
bottles and i don't have
any one of those i have this and you
know what if it doesn't look good to you
so be it uh it has made me uh
an unbelievable husband father and
member of the community
and in my opinion that's why i have this
america flag tattooed in my
arm and i'll continue to stand for
freedom
[ __ ] just [ __ ]
blow it up dude that's awesome man
well what do you think what's the next
step
like where's the nfl going man where and
then
maybe after that you know what's your
opinion on this
government and well look at john boehner
john boehner
retired from being the speaker of the
house to be head of canopy growth
that's crazy you know so that's where
it's going i mean i think at the end of
the day
the writing's on the wall all of these
guys are
all these guys are getting into the
business yeah you know the businesses
yeah future yeah the projections on this
are too big
you know you you know if you've gotten
involved in the industry
excuse me it could create cbd companies
flower companies brands whatever
um you know where this is going man i
mean
the the projections on all this from the
markets if you're into this i mean the
cbd market alone is supposed to become a
700 billion dollar industry
you know in five years i mean the these
numbers
you're going to be all the sporting
events are going to be sponsored by
cannabis companies uh the stadiums are
going to be sponsored by cannabis
companies that's amazing there's never
been a
larger uh a faster growth in a company
i think than they're they're saying then
this canopy growth group
and they just they just got another i
guess four billion dollars from
uh some big massive distribution company
worldwide
distributor and so and the canadian
stock exchange went crazy
all these stocks are going nuts you know
i mean this guy's the
uh i mean and we'll see you know there's
always been that there that opportunity
but they've always wanted to fight
against it and they're continuing to
fight against it you know and so
with all this even though all the things
that we you know sit here talk about
it just you know just goes over these
people's heads the
of of who are making the decisions on
you know
you know the rules i i think sessions
gone is good but
we'll see the new guy is a football guy
uh and so i'm hoping that he
listens to this conversation and what
you know
we're trying to say you know and that
this is taking us away because he he
knows that
world i know he knows that world this
new ag knows pill world
i know that this guy was on a lot of
them you know because he played the game
and he went to a big school played at
iowa i think
played football at iowa was a tight end
or a lineman okay
um and so i'm hoping that he listens to
guys like us yeah you know what do you
think mike
i mean i'm just wondering what's going
to ever happen with this situation it
was ever going to stop or we would ever
get a chance where cannabis is going to
be legal in this country
yeah i think we're getting real close to
it
yeah there's too much science behind it
it's like just pure ignorance to ignore
it you know it's just stupidity in my
opinion
yeah there's just too much backing it
now eventually it will
you know um in my opinion yeah
the cbd is the way in you know the cbd i
mean if we
yeah that's what i've i try to tell
everyone if the people with support
you know cause even you know the problem
is you have a lot of infighting as well
you know the industry fights against
itself and the you know full plant
versus hemp and like oh we got this war
like we need to fight for the plant we
are we're all fighting for the plan
right everybody needs to relax here and
understand there if we can
get this door open which we have with
cbd
then it all comes in because we have to
talk about the entourage effect and
um you know at the end of the day it's
not it's it is going to become like you
say science it's not about
uh anyone's opinion or all these
semantics
uh it should be and hopefully you know
science now will have
uh its say in this because um i guess
they uh
just descheduled uh you know cbd and all
these other things
uh uh apparently
so that they can start doing you know
government testing so that's ten years i
think is what their timeline is
um but uh epidilex is supposed to hit
the
shelves at walgreens the cbd that the
uh yeah the government federalists call
it costs like three grand
yeah it's like so crazy um that has to
be prescribed or it's over
yeah yeah yeah epididylex yeah and
that's the one with the
fda approved cbd that's supposed to hit
the shelves i guess here in december
um crazy yeah 3 000 for one month
supply yeah whatever it is you know
that's crazy
yeah but it's horrible yeah but at the
end of the day what that's going to do
is going to prove
you know you're going to have all these
prescribed patients and
and you're going to see just with that
alone uh
all those people start to get off all
those other pills yeah
and they're just going to be going back
and getting their epidialects like and
then they're going to get off of vicodin
they're going to get off of
you know that's what epidialex is going
to do i think um
yeah you know hopefully that's what it
does
no that makes sense i mean that really
makes sense yeah what do you think about
the nfl
i mean where where are we with that uh
we'll see
i've had conversations with uh their
chief medical officer which was real
interesting uh
interesting phone call it's been about
two hours on the phone with him that's a
good call
yeah about a month ago i think it was
yeah um
so we'll see where that goes you know if
the nfl can acknowledge this as a
neuroprotectant i mean we're in a
situation boxing i mean
uh they don't want to acknowledge cte
but they acknowledge
you know dementia pugilistica you know
which is what you have
we're just a little shade behind you you
know
we're in the same boat because of all
the head trauma that we experienced as
contact sport athletes and it's the same
thing but they
pigeonhole it to uh well boxing is
pigeon you know
pugilistic dementia pugilistica nfl is
cte
you know this is alzheimer's disease
isn't it
no it's not it's it's the it's all the
[ __ ] same right
and you guys they keep chopping it up
you know uh but at the end of the day
the amazing thing about all of this
no matter what sport and what you want
to call this brain disease
there's not one other neuroprotective
patent in the world on
any other substance
other than cannabis right nobody no
government
no no you know heavily funded uh
research group has come up with anything
yeah that's patented that they've
deemed worthy of patenting
other than the united states government
they're
on alzheimer's.org on their main page
they say there is no known uh you know
medication that stops the progression of
alzheimer's disease they say it on their
website on alzheimer's.org
which is a government website for
alzheimer's
the studies show that cannabis stops the
progression of alzheimer's disease
it's crazy you know if if football can
acknowledge this
or you know uh if i continue to we can
continue to press this towards
i met with the boxing commission in
vegas i don't know if you've met with
those guys i went in and met with them i
knocked on their door i said i really
want to talk to you guys about this
because if a major sports league um you
know i've been a vase i've been to vegas
talked to the boxing commission
the place right downtown uh and i've
gotten to the nfl if these major sports
organizations if you know get dana white
and get these groups on board where this
is a problem
you know with your community it's going
to continue to be a problem for your
community it's going to result in
suicides and
dementia and alzheimer's and all these
other diseases that
don't necessarily have to happen to your
community
you know and if they can acknowledge
that this is
a time where we need to have something
uh now you know that's that's all i'm
trying to do because
they they keep you know kicking the can
goodell keeps kicking the can
the the boxing commission they'll keep
kicking the can
saying well we've got to wait for the
federal government to do what they're
gonna do
so okay so no so we're gonna have
now again another football season um
as i told evan uh they just showed the
episode that i
taped with the doctors i was on the
doctor's show yeah yeah and i exposed
this information to them
uh this is dr phil's network you know
these are powerful people
you know dr phil is a powerful man i was
on a show that he produces in his studio
in l.a
called the doctors and i exposed that
there is
a neuroprotective patent on cannabis i
expose that we don't have to have
these deaths in football in youth
football every year 20 kids
die from high school to
young college kids and to pop warner and
it's a it's an inevitability every year
10 to 20 kids die in football i don't
know what the numbers are in boxing but
i'm sure they have a death rate
you know very high yeah it's high and
and uh and so
i exposed this like a year ago they
finally aired it at the end of the
football season which is great they
aired it you know
but uh and now i'm getting to these
conversations with these people but
you know these kids keep dying they need
to be uh uh
you know they they need to be held
accountable you know there's something
here
we we shouldn't just be waiting for the
federal government they should be
pushing the federal government to say
look
not just roger goodell be able to say
well
our doctors don't think it's necessary
to to look into this you know yeah uh or
don't don't believe in the f
like who cares like well i think one of
the problems
is the nfl doesn't look at it as they
have a community
of people they look at it as we're the
nfl
and we need to protect this image this
shield
because you know who are any of these
guys
without us yeah well they'll continue to
just be
uh a bunch of alzheimer's patients right
you know
when you don't have to have this we
don't junior say i should
still be here uh all these guys should
still be here
yeah you know uh our our friends don't
don't have to be
uh suffering suffering the way they are
with these
neurological diseases i had vertigo
some of the problems i was having
outside of emotional you know
distress and dealing with the real world
and divorce and whatever
i started to have real neurological
problems surface
i had started have vertigo i don't know
if you had that you know i'm sure
i've had just get dizzy out of nowhere
so i started have vertigo constantly
throughout my nfl career
to the point when i retired uh partially
because of
a bunch of bone chips in my shoulder i
couldn't raise my arm up
you know past this i needed a full ankle
reconstruction another back surgery
uh then you know all of a sudden uh
at the end of my career i couldn't smack
myself in the head to get ready to go
out on the field anymore
um because i would start to get dizzy
you know and so i had to stop doing
these things and then after my career
almost every day having to deal with
vertigo
at some point uh you know having
migraine headaches constantly i don't
know where you're starting to feel dizzy
yeah out of nowhere just i don't know i
could be driving uh
and i it's happened to me twice so i had
that
for years 20 years vertigo
for the last four and a half years i've
been off opiates and strictly on campus
i have not had vertigo
once it was inevitable every year
on every team that i would be on they'd
be i would have to
they would put me in a dark room i would
show up in full vertigo i'd get a ride
to the you know have somebody come pick
me up because i didn't want to miss
practice
you know and i'd go to the facility
puking in trash cans
um um like just non-stop constantly
they put me in the dark room they bring
doctor in they put iv in me
they go out to practice they come back
in and wake me up
and uh um and i'd finish out the day of
meetings and watching film and watching
the guys at practice
this would happen every year on every
team at least once
yeah and would they give you painkillers
too well you know yeah i mean we were
just getting dosed up with all that back
then i mean
shoot you up as well yeah twirled shots
constantly
you know toward all um
cortisone shots any injury just
dosed up with cortisone like crazy yeah
i mean i was
i had a back injury that they'd hid from
me just shooting me up with cortisone
it's insane man yeah yeah kyle you need
another massage before the game you know
you're just sticking these
on yeah you know no they tell you hey
this is gonna make you feel better
yeah that's all at the end of the day
you want to do you know
yeah um this can get me out there uh
at my at my lowest point i i was willing
to do anything
fast too yeah yeah oh yeah super fast
[ __ ] man yeah well kyle i mean you're
such a presence man you're
one of my idols all time thank you man
another dude with dragon's blood running
through his veins
um what are you up to now man i know
you're you're
heavily involved in the cannabis space
you've got your own companies
talk a little bit about that give a
shout out to your companies and
and what else you're doing these days
yeah a lot going on um you know i mean
as we've talked about it
uh you know and started into this we see
the opportunities to
you know not just get into this uh as a
you know conversation but really
showcase uh
what this is about you know when you
have a platform to do so
um you know and you have the right
people around you
you know then then you can really start
to change this conversation
and really start to shift this and i've
seen that i've seen that now
since we you know our first one that we
did in arizona and we did this
convention
uh and now to where we are today where
we're not just at conventions we got
booths and
we're promoting these brands and
companies and we've got great people
around us with all this
you know killer marketing and branding
and uh
and really crafting this message you
know i i've found that that you need to
you need to do that you know if you have
a voice in this industry
you should get in the industry because
you know
the way that you can articulate uh you
know your
knowledge or opinions about this and how
you want the world to see it
um you know comes in the forms of logos
and and all these other things
and um uh at the end of the day that's
the conduit that's the thing that you
know
when i discovered cbd and the power of
cbd i was like
holy [ __ ] this i could get this to
everybody
yeah this is going to work for everybody
you know there's not one person that
hasn't had an experience with the c
this cbd product that uh we're producing
and
and so i was like i i if i can now put
this in this
uh shape of uh like direct it towards
sports and
really expose the neural protective
aspects of cannabis
um you know and really craft this
message then i can get that out there i
can go to super bowls i can talk about
this just like any other company can
you know it's hard to talk about your
brand when it's you know
dank you know this or that or you know
the you know whatever you know what i
mean the the stereotypical
you know stoner stuff you know yeah
you're not you're just not going to
get that message across you know it's
unfortunate we have to do that in
america but
right um to the mainstream if if you're
really trying to progress
this conversation to where it needs to
be that the the right way to do it is
through being in the industry
you know so i started cbd company we
called it neuro armor
and uh we had to change that to neuro
xpf
under armour suit us oh really oh yeah a
bunch of [ __ ] man they think
they own the word armor neuro xpf and
you can go to neuroxpf.com uh we've got
a great website
and you know tell my story and uh you
know
like we're all trying to do man and just
get the medicine to the people you know
if you if you find
any cbd product out there uh or cannabis
product out there that's that's good you
know use it
whether it's mine or type mics you know
years whatever
yeah whatever it is you know and then so
i did that and then i've been
working on a cultivation project um
you know working with containers
shipping containers yeah
uh
you can growpodssolutions.com to that
growpodssolutions.com and
uh that opportunity is incredible man uh
you can isolate
you know strains in these things you can
build environments that are
just unbelievably sterile and efficient
it's like uh
the susie breadmaker deal you know
your little sister had growing up yeah
you can turn key these things and
produce
x amount in each one of them you know
what i mean so if you
you want one at your house or you had a
shop
or you know somewhere these things are
running on 14 amps of power
like and producing like unbelievably
killer
weed um yeah man and then just trying to
continue to
search for more opportunities i want a
distribution license in my hometown
in mourinho valley that's awesome a
dispensary
uh we were in the queue
as the city council says uh as we got
drawn about just about dead last in the
lottery
uh for uh uh retail license
um okay but we won the distribution we
got a great facility out there working
with the group chango
out of las vegas on that project and
this is awesome yeah you know hopefully
some other projects come into
shape here you know things we've talked
about you know
um you know love to you know it's always
about the collaboration man
you know i'm about the progressing this
making my my fight is for the plan
everything i do you know people oh is
that for the money no
i want to work with mike i want to work
with you i went with everybody man
because we need to get this plant
legalized and to where it is just
the the same cost of a box of cigarettes
or
you know whatever you know uh as it
should be
and everybody should have that
opportunity
no doubt dude yeah well it's awesome man
and uh we appreciate you coming down
really we do yeah thank you man i
appreciate it mike thank you brother
it's really awesome great to be here
have to have you back anytime yeah man
it's good it feels good yeah yeah hell
yeah you're still making country music
yeah you know what actually uh still
doing the music thing um
doing a lot of writing lately you know i
got little kids so
super busy with them and you know just
love being a dad and but i'm getting
itch
i've been writing a lot more lately you
know having this
experience with cannabis and recovering
your life is a great
a great thing you start to see all these
things
come back into your life you know music
is one of those passions that i
went after just like football after uh
the game was over for me and i moved to
nashville and
i did it for six years i traveled coast
to coast i played with all the top
names in country music from uh george
jones before he died i mean i was
wow epic i got to open up a show for
george jones i played with
hank three dave falco leonard skinner
eric church when eric church was just
getting big man
opened up shows for him and jake owen
and all these guys
i mean you know i had this really cool
experience that
i was trying to you know build a career
music on and uh
and it and it and it had to take a you
know its own pause because of
my health you know i got to that point
of needing to address my health
you know i was going for uh years you
know post career
in and out of doctor's offices getting
prescribed medications
just piling up pills going to rehab
facilities to try and figure this out
why am i depressed i've got money i've
got the wife i've got the
the kids i've got it all the cars why do
i feel
so horrible all day every day you know
why does this life
you know why is this become something
that i consider not worth living
and that was the wake up call for me you
know is that this was becoming constant
and
worse and i got to that point where i
just decided
i've got to get off all these pills and
use this one thing that i know since the
first time i used it
has been there for me not once has it
ever failed me not once his cannabis
ever failed me
it was always that one thing in any
situation you're ever in pain
wise uh you know mental state-wise
whatever that can resolve it like that
you know
it's it's almost immediate you know as
soon as you
get that first you know breath in uh
in in a situation of stress or anxiety
or pain
or anything you know everything's gonna
be all right
you know what i mean and that feeling
man like
having that happen has just ignited the
music thing in me again
i've been coaching football i i mean a
couple
i just barely you know
settled in in that i'm not coming back
to play in the nfl anymore
because you will for forever you know
you always want to go back
you always think you can you got one
more round you got one more down you
know what i mean
yeah so i've come to that
that uh uh conceit concession
at 43. finally we used to kill it man we
were we were good man i had some great
players
and uh we hit it hard man we we had fun
it was a good time man what was the name
of your band i just did the kyle turley
band
hell yeah i did a metal band at one
point too we toured with some uh
pretty good band like crowbar and some
other uh doom metal heavy doom metal
bands
um in the south when i was living in
nashville but
the country thing was just my name i
wrote everything
you can see it's on youtube and on uh
pandora and all that punching and kyle
turley and go the station
and get a lot of southern rock and uh
old school country new school country
you know it was fun man it's awesome
i know yeah well man i really appreciate
you
being here always good you're the man
mike thank you another great one brother
oh no blowing up
another great one mike great to be here
nick thanks for stopping
thanks for having me again you're the
man until next time guys
we're out of here peace
[Music]
[Music]
you